a little over a year ago president trump
sat down for an interview with leslie
stahl in which he complained that the
democrats and the deep state
spied on his presidential campaign
and leslie stahl was having none of it
she pushed back she dismissed the claims
she said the charge was baseless
so the biggest scandal was when they
spied on my campaign they spied on my
campaign there's no real evidence of
that of course there is it's all over
the place leslie they spied on my
campaign and they got caught can i say
something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify put it on because it's bad for
abiding we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
well we can't very it's funny i'm
totally verified no
it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my campaign they got
caught no and then they went much
further than that and they got caught
and you will see that leslie and you
know that but you just don't want to put
it over here as a matter of fact i don't
know that
no no no la la la no this is 60 minutes
this totally crazy you're a conspiracy
theorist how dare you make such a whoops
whoops here it is turns out he was
totally right
totally
100 right as of
just a few days ago
we now have firm proof that not only did
hillary clinton affiliates spy on donald
trump when he was a candidate
but they even went so far as to spy on
him when he was president
all in a desperate effort to frame him
for colluding with the russians
something democrats have been doing for
100 years according to special counsel
john durham's latest doj report
quote
the government's evidence at trial will
also establish that among the internet
data tech executive one and his
associates
uh exploited was domain name system
internet traffic pertaining to
one a particular healthcare provider two
trump tower three donald trump central
park west apartment building
and four
the executive office of the president of
the united
states trump reacted to the news in
exactly the way you would expect saying
quote this is a scandal far greater in
scope and magnitude than watergate and
those who were involved in and knew
about this spying operation should be
subject to criminal prosecution in a
stronger period of time in our country
this crime would have been punishable by
death
classic trump
pushing the window of acceptable speech
rightward getting people to accept
prosecution as the moderate position
with
execution as the further right solution
and by the way he's right on that front
too espionage can be a capital offense
and spying on the sitting president is
about as serious
as it gets so we now know
that the democrats themselves did
basically everything they accused trump
of doing
we know that trump has been proven right
on some of his wildest claims sitting
there with leslie stahl oh no this is
crazy it's a conspiracy theory some of
his wildest claims completely correct
who knows how many more wild claims he
will be vindicated on especially now
that we know the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth is about
six to 18 months we know this is one of
the most egregious abuses of power in
u.s history
and we know that not only are the
democrats not the responsible and
patriotic adults in the room that
they've made themselves out to be but
their behavior is somehow even more
depraved than their most trenchant
critics thought i'm glad you liked that
clip now
please ring that bell subscribe
you can get the notifications here when
our new videos come out and if you don't
you can head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
podcast leave a five star review we will
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you